hey guys it's mkbhd with today's top
Twitter tips and tricks be sure to share
this video on Twitter just to get the
word out and hopefully people are doing
it right so tip number one don't tweet
too much this one's pretty simple if
you've tweeted more than 15,000 times
you've tweeted too much just woke up
getting dressed showered food more food
thank you tip number two is actually
tweet if you've set up a Twitter account
and you didn't tweet you're doing it
wrong
tip number three don't tweet about what
you're eating because what goes in one
hole is only slightly more interesting
than what goes out the other tip number
four don't tweet asking people to follow
you chances are only people who are
going to see that tweet is people who
are already following you so use that
logic to yeah tip number five tweeting
about how much you hate Twitter is not
going to solve the problem no matter
what you think and also tweeting at
companies to fix stuff usually doesn't
work either I don't know if you realized
tip number six don't ever tweet on the
toilet please ever ever please thank you
number seven retweet if you got to be
careful with those really yeah that
one's not that bad
that one's bad that one's also pretty
bad that one's worse number eight don't
ever tweet that number nine
do not throw a Twitter temper tantrum
online if you must rant keep it
civilized
keep it three tweets or less and don't
spam the timelines of people who just
don't care number ten understand that
99% of what you tweet is a hundred
percent public so don't tweet pictures
of your